gratuit / application / carburant égal 30 pour prendre
la note d'un autre évident se produire sans
aller jusqu'à 17 dire à propos de ces
vacances rivière sud baba bénédiction fait
le plus important que vous vous priiez de vous repositionner
d'accord si des buissons sont ces
packs achèteront un hélicoptère
c'était de très bons enfants qui travaillaient là
-bas et moi, il faisait CBS, nous pouvions passer à
travers un long post un, alors je suis allé
là-bas vers trois heures du matin,
donnie a mis le câble de mise à la terre sur l'
hélicoptère, j'ai dit au gamin que j'ai dit
hop je vais voler à l'autre bout il n'a
pas enlevé le câble de mise à la terre nous sommes
rentrés chez nous depuis la rampe et sommes presque allés dans l'
eau et je sais ce que j'ai même trouvé
ces quatre heures hein
heureusement j'ai senti l'hélicoptère se faire dire
que nous  ont pu l'arrêter de
rouler ouais oh ouais c'est un beau
moment ici, je peux obtenir un petit salut
obtenir un bon coup de pied de l'eau des
bâtiments coraniques cette union aujourd'hui pas de
dr.  Température de Steven,
ils ne croyaient pas au bord de la rivière qui
se produisait d'accord, on dirait que quelqu'un
essaie de prendre votre travail ici, nous sommes à
la frontière 30 golf d'écho
nous séparent pour 44
astuce d'inversion de cours de dame arrière mais à propos d'ikea élégant être
que c'est le problème pour le 49e engel
beltre est allé à Western 5 vous êtes clair
pour le parc du centre-ville j'en ai un planant
sur chacun dessus faites du sel et Ravel
top 30 pieds le couper à  1 000 qu'est-ce
que je voulais faire quelques photos avec le
petit appareil photo mais pour te tuer New York
ça fait des centaines va mettre le frigo
personne n'a pensé que c'était plus facile mais spécial
pour lui plein d'hôtel tu es
autorisé à la sortie Raju je veux dire  ça va au
centre-ville prenez-le entre la porte
vers le bas soit je n'ai jamais la batterie
ici si nous prenons un ferry vous êtes clair
devant Bravo frères un nous avons été
refusés au tango Douglas appel jeu
batterie terminée pour le gouverneur 600
ce que j'ai apparu sur cinquième  gouverner  nance
500 Je mec entre les gouverneurs et le
trafic fluvial du jeu Cole p12 vient de penser au BG
500 pris en bas Oh Steven arrête
notre chaleur sous cette fille qui
cherche à faire le tour des Carnales
la droite ici à gauche la lèvre
maintenant ça pourrait être  une belle ombre l'
élevant comme 2 000 pieds a vu l'île du gouverneur au-
dessus de 900 corbett grove ouais
ils ne sont pas ensemble boo souris survolez et
ensuite vous inclinez simplement la caméra depuis le
montage ouais quoi de neuf et les incendies doivent
remplir les ponts ouais je pourrais définir  moi,
vous pouvez trouver Manhattan comme étant un
je vais essayer, j'ai balancé la
casquette pour jouer au hockey, alors nous patinons des
jouets ouais d'accord, nous allons bien
y aller pour le loup sur la droite, accrochez-vous
un peu plus loin pour  le jeune West
ce serait bien tu
continues à dormir seul le poète qui le
prend comme un ouais là
Alex plutôt gentil hein
oh ils sont allés boum d'accord et je
vais monter un peu hein j'ai levé les yeux 128
ogawa gordito  personne à six points votre
o  wn music 28-0 ouais ça
mettrait beaucoup de nourriture
comment ça hey bonne chance merci
merci Lydia hélicoptère doux délicat
juste à l'ouest de la statue ou 2012 permet un
vrai je fais la même chose avec la statue
ouais ouais alors tout  le lourd ils ont rempli
et ils étaient des costumes de clown nos toges que
vous avez mis l'écureuil j'ai raté le numéro
je veux dire je suppose le numéro du toronto
à entretenir avec Nancy moi pour faire ils ont l'
air si très gentils monsieur fermez ce que vous avez
dit comme ça  pour nous ouais nous l'obtenons
à droite je vais bien ouais donne
ça un autre meilleur 19e
anniversaire c'est nos sites vraiment sympa pour tango
Delta Roger maintenir la séparation visuelle
ok maintenant si je descends peut-être passer le
statut dans le problème venteux  c'est plutôt
bien j'en ai gardé un peu et assez
je fais la fête jusqu'au couvercle cinq tu viens
tu prends ma main gentiment ouais on a compris
je vais prendre un avis quelle bonne idée
Pete le pilote bon ouais très bien prends
un 1 41  vous entrez avec votre plaisir merci
vous avez un bon kic  k juste à côté de ce
bâtiment patio acceptable ok à l'avant
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment mettre mon eau
tu regardes bien nous serions dans la vidéo
vers le centre-ville ouais ils décident de faire
des photos verticales des gens à
ce rythme ce que les autres sont des organes inquiétants
nous pouvons  apportez-le de la terre et faites-le monter
à LaGuardia comment ça va non je dois
penser à la largeur oh ouais et si je
pouvais le lui apporter humide et aller
travailler à LaGuardia pouvez-vous continuer à
tirer vous ne le roulez pas oh ouais
c'est  bien, vous allez remonter l'
Hudson, en fait, vous aimez aller juste au-dessus
du centre d'une chance de dépoussiérer les travaux
pendant que nous faisons un 1500 pour l'instant et ensuite
vous pouvez transmettre ce reflash avec eux
lorsque vous allez au nord-est qui fonctionne aussi
sur un  tournez-vous vers le bon régime cette
tenue puis-je avoir le foie pourquoi
nos 126 points sont vraiment rapides assurez-
vous d'aider à positionner le cordial 40 trop
emmêlés jusqu'au tango Delhi pensez-vous que je
pensais que cette découverte est hors de Newark
tout ce que je pourrais avoir  deux mille nous  Je
serai au sud d'un peu de réseau de cul
endommagé Je provisionne la quadrature
sans la maintenabilité mille Je
viens
de parler de la société neuf Tana
Delta donc nous sommes euh